[Musique]
au fil des semaines plusieurs cabinets
de conseils sont également auditionné
l'un d'entre eux attire particulièrement
l'attention
mckinsey géant mondial du conseil
présent dans 45 pays dans le monde
certaines prestations interroge les
sénateurs vous avez obtenu un contrat
d'un montant de 480 ch à 6800 euros
pour je cite
évaluer les évolutions du métier
d'enseignant d'enseignants vous pouvez
nous dire à quoi aboutit cette mission
oui ps madame la rapporteure c'est un
nous avons été sollicités dans le cadre
du contrat cadre de la dtp par le
ministère de par le mi5 de les doubler
plus mystère de l'éducation et par la
dtp et notre rôle a été d'accompagner la
dtp pour organiser un séminaire qui
était prévu par le ministère en lien
avec ceux d'organisations
internationales pour réfléchir à quelles
étaient les grandes tendances
d'évolution de marcher près de 500000
euros pour préparer une réflexion pour
un colloque qui n'a jamais eu lieu voilà
je crois que ça peut interroger et tout
le monde même ceux qui ne sont pas
connaisseur des affaires publiques mais
plus encore et rendons hommage au
président basa c'est quand arnaud la
pose la question sur les impôts là vous
êtes soumis aux impôts français comme
nom pour bien sûr s'il était bien sûr
monsieur le président merci
et je le dis très nettement nous payons
l'impôt sur les sociétés en france et
l'ensemble des salariés qui travaillent
sinon si tu es droit français qui paie
ses impôts en france l'aplomb avec
lequel cette assertion est faite par
monsieur tadjeddine j'avoue pour aller
nous laisser penser qui a même pas
besoin d'aller vérifier cependant nous
en avions bien l'intention et nous
l'avons fait c'est à dire qu'avec madame
à ça si nous nous sommes rendus au
ministère de l'économie et des finances
nous avons constaté que pendant dix ans
cette entreprise avait fait un résultat
négatif qu'elle avait perdu de l'argent
tous les ans et qu'en conséquence il
n'avait pas payé d'impôts sur les
bénéfices et pourquoi ce s'il n'y avait
pas de bénéfices et donc
monsieur tadjeddine nous a menti ou
monsieur tadjeddine s'est trompé c'était
la justice d'établir s'il y avait une
intention pas c'est la rencontre en fait
de cet argent dépensé sur une mission qu
aurait pu être réalisés par des
enseignants eux-mêmes et le fait que
mckinsey les présumés ne pas payer
d'impôt sur les sociétés en france donc
c'est un scandale c'est un scandale la
presse monsieur technique at il dit
c'est s'est longuement
penché sur votre rôle pendant la
campagne électorale du président macro
notamment c'est un moment de tension
importante puisque là on touche à des
matières très sensible au coeur de
l'état avez vous effectué donc des
missions dans le cadre de l'élection
présidentielle karim tadjeddine botte en
touche et ne répondra pas sur ses liens
avec la campagne des manuels macron de
2017 mais les sénateurs s'interrogent
également sur l'engagement de certains
salariés de l'entreprise toujours dans
la même dans la même veine une vingtaine
de salariés
de votre société aurait participé donc à
7 à cette campagne comment avez vous
assurez les règles liées au conflit
d'intérêts comme vous le savez la loi
française est extrêmement correctrices
des libertés individuelles de chacun
pourra participer à des activités
politiques associatives ou collectif et
donc moi en tant qu'employeur elle n'est
pas habilitée ne serait-ce qu'à demander
à une personne et elle exerce des
activités ou une implication politique
pour nous mêmes membres de la commission
denquête c'est problématique parce que
nous pouvons craindre s'il y a eu ce
genre d'engagement bénévole de salariés
en nombre quand même d'une entreprise de
conseil privé dans une campagne
électorale il y ait un risque un moment
quelconque de retour d'ascenseur
[Musique]